when I'm Alana coming at you from a
hotel in LA so the video quality is not
great it's cuz I'm on my webcam I figure
out to bring my camera if you can hear a
band in the background of people talking
it's it's just because this is not an
ideal circumstance to make a video hello
Wow frame rate beautiful so this is a
topic that isn't particularly new but
I've seen it so many times that I
decided to finally make a video about it
this is a response to a blog post that
went up that was titled sexy cosplayers
need to be stopped the post has since
been deleted but it was shared a fair
bit and it's ultimately that content
doesn't matter because there are so many
other articles that are similar to this
I found one with a quick google search
from 2012 called why cosplay girls annoy
the [ __ ] out of me
but you also see the cosplay community
itself eating at each other over the way
that other people choose to dress and I
just I don't get it I don't understand
it there are different kinds of cosplay
there are people who buy their costumes
there are people who tailor their
costumes there are people who buy
different items and adjust them and put
it all together there are people who
build that Amin from scratch there are
people who make every part of it from
scratch all of these things are cosplay
I genuinely believe that even if you are
wearing a brown underwear and you have a
wig and makeup styled after a character
and it is a photoshoot themed after that
character it's still cosplay and I
understand people have different quality
standards I personally don't feel like
I'm cosplaying unless I've made like at
least some part of my costume and the
creative process of putting all the
things together is probably the most fun
part for me aside from being at a
convention and meeting other cosplayers
and especially meeting kids who are
really excited to see you but if you're
a person who just buys everything still
cosplay when it comes to the concept of
[ __ ] cosplay there are kind of like
two sides of this one that comes from
the cosplay community itself is well she
gets more attention than me because she
posts cosplay that has boobs and that's
not fair because they work so hard and I
want the attention I don't think that's
on the fault of the person who has boobs
and is flaunting them I
think the problem is more so that you're
cosplaying for attention and comparing
yourself to someone else on that scale
of how much attention you get if you
want attention that's fine humans like
attention that's it's a thing we need to
not go crazy
but the thing I would urge you to
consider if you are of this mentality is
community not competition the cosplay
community when it isn't competitive is
so so welcoming you meet so many
different kinds of people who are
willing to help you with different
things share their love for these
characters they're dressing up as and
just have a [ __ ] great weekend at a
convention the minute the competition
thing comes in is when it starts getting
catty and shitty and you start caring
about the way someone else dresses based
on it not being the same as your
standards and you're allowed to have
cosplay standards you're allowed to have
your own set of rules for what you
define as cosplay as soon as you start
pushing that on someone else or you
start saying someone else has more
attention than you because they don't do
the thing that is to your standard
you're the one that's the dick not them
you're the one being a jerk it's it
doesn't matter this is the same
conversation that comes around twitch
streamers and youtubers they call like
titty streamers people who have that
boobs out when they're streaming all
these people hurting anyone else who
doesn't have their boobs out while
streaming no so that's what I would say
to cosplays community not competition
the second part which was like the
thesis of this blog post is just the
logic that if you cosplay as characters
who wear anything revealing or if you
adapt a character who is generally
modest to wear something revealing that
you are a lesser cosplayer or even like
a lesser person get that out just get it
out of your head if someone wants to
pose in a bra and underwear it doesn't
make the Machine person it's shocking I
know they could be sexually expressive
they could be a person who really enjoys
that part of that body they enjoy posing
in certain ways depending on the photos
this is how they express their
creativity and being a sexually
expressive or sexually open person is
not inherently a bad thing not even not
inherently it's just straight up not a
bad thing it's okay if you post pictures
in bikinis on the internet a lot it
doesn't mean that all you care about is
your appearance
it doesn't mean that you don't want
anyone to take you seriously as a human
and it doesn't mean that you can't like
geeky things cuz that's a big one this
has happened to me people will be like
oh you posted a picture in a bikini oh I
thought you were a video game journalist
it's like wait what
how did how are those two things related
can i web bikinis and also be like holy
[ __ ] great day the beach and also have
the job that I have that I went to
university for that I've been doing for
seven years no why because those two
things aren't mutually exclusive you can
be someone who is sexual and a model and
has huge boobs that they like flaunting
but you can also be creative and enjoy
crafting and enjoy having fun at
conventions and like ultimately be doing
it for a good reason and not competing
with other people like those two things
don't I don't know why people like boobs
evil cover it up talented like it just
doesn't make sense to me it's such a
leap in logic and I guess it's the
extended part of the fake geek culture
where people just really want to find a
reason to rule out someone's nerd cred
to make sure they're not a real nerd
here's a paragraph that I think
describes majority of the reaction of
this outside of the cosplay community am
i bitte absolutely 100% why because as
someone who grew up being ostracized for
being a dork ass outsider someone who
was routinely ridiculed by girls for not
liking sports and trendy music I can ID
shallow [ __ ] from a mile away and it
pisses me the hell off to see girls who
most assuredly would have been treating
no boys like lepers in middle school now
capitalizing on their attention later in
life because being a nerd is cool which
is one of my favorite things to read
because I was also a nerd in school and
people say [ __ ] like this to me all the
time I feel like I can almost guarantee
that all of the cosplayers you see that
you think of fake notes who bullied you
in school probably [ __ ] weren't if
they were don't bully them back that's
not gonna help you
people can change people can grow and if
they want to be a part of your community
that's ultimately good for everyone the
more people we have at conventions the
more people by much the more people
support the industry it's good for
everyone because we get more stuff and
it can be annoying to feel like you're
being lied to by someone who's like
faking an interest in something but I
think a better option than to be a dick
about it
and
them removed from old conventions
because they're showing cleavage Joel
whatever it is this time is to take the
pretense of interest that might be
slightly false or exaggerated and
introduce them to things that you might
think they would like so they're not
fake anymore so they're just another
person who we can talk to you about this
[ __ ] so we get more of it and everyone's
happy I don't know those are just my
thoughts sorry if this was a random one
but seriously I have to give a huge
thanks to everyone whose names are on
screen right now also patreon already
has listened to the first episode of the
podcast that's so exciting for anyone
who missed the announcement I'm starting
a podcast with my best friend mahdi
first episode will be up February 14th
and then every two weeks after that and
I'm very excited for you guys here and
it's like storytelling comedy
relationship mixture of all of that kind
of stuff so it goes totally off the
rails but we also like talking about a
bunch of weird [ __ ] we found on
Craigslist so excited if you guys hear
it alrighty thank you so much everyone I
will see you guys next time that way